we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two David P I've talked
about activism that works many times on
the show and today's caller brings up a
really good question about exactly this
issue take a listen hey David I have a
question why isn't America saying to
hell with this current regime that's in
the White House why aren't we merging
through the streets of Washington and
the Southlands why have we just gotten
used to the abuses of human rights that
this current regime has enforced or I
don't know it's just it's messed up man
people would be marching to the streets
of Washington saying to hell with this
and you know having like a Hong Kong
type mobilization of protest that's
exactly right and the reason why people
aren't is a feature of the system not a
bug
I've talked about this before if people
need to work multiple jobs in order to
make ends meet if people are working in
hourly positions with limited time off
and the inability to take a day off and
go protest if people just can't afford
to take a bus or drive into the nearest
urban area where one of these mass
gatherings in order to protest are
taking place they're not going to be
able to do it they're not going to do it
and this is exactly why we have a
self-perpetuating vicious cycle in our
economy wages are stagnant inequality
goes up the average person increasingly
is held hostage by wages that haven't
gone up and mediocre or terrible health
insurance that they still absolutely
need to continue getting through their
employers so what does that mean
that they don't have the wherewithal the
resources or the ability or the free
time to actually go and become activists
in order to change that same system that
prevents them from going and becoming
activists it's a circle okay
I've talked about this so many times and
the caller is absolutely right have we
become accustomed to this new
era of scandal no longer being scandal
yes a little bit we have it happens to
all of us I talked about it last week
outrageous stuff has become normal in a
sense or we have in a way become sort of
numb to it because it's exhausting for
everything to be a scandal every single
day so things that should be scandals
aren't because their scandals every day
but the other effect of this is that it
actually the very system that so
desperately needs to be changed is part
of what prevents us from actually going
out and becoming activists to change the
system and the corporation's love that
and the sources of power that maintain
this status quo
love that that is a feature of the
system and unless we change that if less
we break that cycle one way or another
unfortunately nothing is going to change
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we will talk about beta O'Rourke
revealing that he and his wife are
descended from slave owners we will talk
about Amazon workers protesting prime
day and we will also talk about the
Puerto Rican governor define calls to
resign over some text chat scandals that
have arisen all of those stories and
more on the David Pakman show bonus show
two ways to get access to it become a
member at WWE pakman.com become a patron
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
I'll speak to you then